[Musique]
bonsoir vous n'y aurait sans doute pas
dans quelques semaines vont avoir lieu
les élections présidentielles et sixième
du genre en effet c'est en 1965 il y a
trente ans exactement que pour la
première fois le président de la
république a été élu au suffrage
universel
nous allons donc raconter ce soir
pourquoi et comment le général de gaulle
à en 1962 réformer la constitution de
1958 nous allons raconter pourquoi et
comment c'est françois mitterrand qui a
été le candidat unique de la gauche nous
allons raconter les petits et grands
secrets les petites et grandes surprises
d'un scrutin qui à l'époque était
nouveau pour les français avec
l'intrusion de la télévision et des
sondages et qui reste aujourd'hui encore
riche d'enseignements nous allons
raconter tout cela avec des images
d'archivés en noir et blanc c'était
l'époque et avec des témoignages celui
de claude estier qui était dans l'état
major de campagne de françois mitterrand
celui de gilles martinet qui était un
des dirigeants du ps eut celui d'alain
peyrefitte qui était ministre de
l'information du général de gaulle et
qui a recueilli à l'époque bien des
confidences avec enfin le recul les
analyses les commentaires d'olivier
duhamel professeur de droit spécialisé
la constitution et politologues et tout
de suite retour en arrière
le 18 mars 1962 les accords d'evian met
fin à huit années de guerre en algérie
l'artisan de cette paix le général de
gaulle le fondateur de la vème
république a été élu président par un
collège de 60000 notable en application
de la constitution de 1958
[Applaudissements]
l'homme du 18-juin recherche le contact
direct avec les français par-dessus une
classe politique pour qu'ils se méfient
il confie en 61 des proches des clapets
sera conclu ils essaieront de me faire
la peau alors j'attaquerai ils ce sont
les partis
page en temps on me dit où on me fait
dire bah oui là c'est pas gentil à mon
égard et par conséquent bien mais après
vous
ce sera la pagaille
alors
de manière à assurer la succession eh
bien je réfléchis
pour printemps 62 de gaulle songe à
modifier la constitution afin que le
président soit élu au suffrage universel
c'était toujours à l'arrière plan de ses
pensées et à moi il en a parlé le 30 mai
1962 il m'a déclaré veillez annoncé que
lors de l'allocution que je prononcerai
à la radio télévision au début de juin
j'indiquerai que je prendrai des
initiatives pour rassurer d'inventivité
des pouvoirs publics ce que j'ai annoncé
officiellement la can en un front de
l'annoncé du 10 mai qu'est ce que ça
veut dire évaluer ça veut dire que nous
allons faire l'élection du président de
la république au suffrage universel
jeudi m'a fait beaucoup voulu vous faire
ça si tôt et dit je veux le faire à
l'automne il pourquoi si tôt après spa
voit bien vous êtes là
vous n'êtes a contesté en tant que chef
de l'état donc le développement ne peut
pas tomber et il m'a dit eh bien
mon âge il faut toujours prendre des
précautions parce qu'on sait jamais ce
qui peut arriver et puis si dos reis
musique ou y ait ce qui se passera et
bien la faillite si oui et justement me
disait
au conseil des ministres qui a précédée
immédiatement le petit clamart il m'a
dit nous france à l'automne et c'était
une demi heure avant que les tuèrent de
l' os du petit clamart et donner une
actualité cruel à ce qu'il voulait faire
et
aussitôt il a compris parce qu'il était
un militaire son oeil d'aigle a compris
le parti tactique qu'il pouvait tirer de
cet attentat et il a même eu une semaine
après une phrase un peu un peu
gouailleuse et presque cynique pour me
dire
cet attentat tombe à pic
il s'est rendu compte que cet attentat
avait soulevé une telle émotion dans le
public que cette réforme qui était très
importante et qui était tout à fait à
contre-courant des pensées de la classe
politique notamment de tous ceux qui
avait régné pendant les douze ans de
4ème république qu'il fallait que
l'opinion appuie bien l'opinion est mûre
pour adopter cette réforme je crois
devoir
faire au pays
la proposition que voici
quand sera terminé mon propre septennat
ou si la mort ou la maladie
l'interrompent est avant le terme
le président de la république sera
dorénavant tu es élu au suffrage
universel
aussitôt c'est le tollé dans la classe
politique
à l'exception des gaullistes de l'umr
tous les autres partis on voit dans
cette réforme renforcement d'un pouvoir
autocratique à caractère publicitaire
le 30 septembre au congrès du parti
radical à vichy gaston monnerville alors
président du sénat parle même de
forfaiture
[Musique]
au delà du fond c'est surtout la
violation de la constitution violation
caractérisée par le président de la
république et le gouvernement qui s'en
est fait le complice que nous avons
unanimement dénoncé rien n'est plus
républicain
rien n'est plus démocratique
j'ajoute que rien n'est plus français
tant cela est clair
simple et droit je ne crois pas qu'ils
imaginaient qui ont accaparé
déchaînement il nous l'a dit mme plus
tard et nous a dit même plus tard je ne
pensais pas que
l'opposition serait aussi déchaîné
qu'elle a été elle a était déchaîné
parce qu'elle jouait le tout pour le
tout l'opposition c'était assez
essentiellement les survivants de la
4ème république et il savait bien que
c'était là une deuxième mort de la 4ème
république
le 5 octobre l'assemblée nationale vote
la censure au pidoux présente la
démission de son gouvernement
mais de gaulle lui demande de rester en
fonction et dissout l'assemblée
ces élections législatives auront donc
lieu un mois après le référendum la
campagne en est que plus virulente de
gaulle mais tout le poids de son
autorité en faveur du oui
si votre réponse est non
comme le voudrait tous les anciens
partis afin de rétablir leurs régimes de
malheur
ainsi que tous les factieux
pour se lancer dans la subversion
ou même
si la majorité des wii
est faible
médiocre aléatoire
il est bien évident que ma tâche sera
terminé
aussitôt et sans retour
car que pourrais-je faire ensuite sans
la confiance chaleureuse de la nation
près de 21 millions de français ont voté
au référendum du 28 octobre la chasse
aux célébrités étant de règles nous
avons surpris en pleine action civique
monsieur pompidou oui
monsieur maurice thorez non
le comte et la comtesse de paris oui
sans doute
monsieur giscard d'estaing oui
guy mollet n'ont évidemment monsieur
antoine pinay peut-être
monsieur monnerville non et enfin le
général de gaulle qui devait rassembler
autour de 100 oui plus de 13 millions
d'écho favorable
il a été profondément déçu et même
prostré parce qu'ils avaient été
habitués par
les résultats des trois premiers
référendum des chiffres astronomiques
des chiffres quasi stalinien puis voilà
que tout à coup on tombait à 62% des
votants c'est à dire seulement 47 % des
inscrits et alors il a été profondément
tata de n'avoir pas la majorité des
inscrits
intérieurement il s'était fixé cette
règle en dessous de la majorité des
inscrits c'est pas légitime il a été
profondément atteints ils voulaient pas
venir vous l'instant que l'on baissé
foutu tca vous savez il était sujet à
ces
crises
cyclothymique puis l'a repris courage et
le résultat des élections législatives
qui ont suivi qui ont montré qu'il avait
une très large majorité de pas fonction
le peuple avait entériné ce vote
en effet un mois plus tard et
législatives complète la victoire du
général le parti qui le soutient lui
nerfs avec 34% des suffrages frôlé la
majorité en sièges à l'assemblée
pompidou peut former son deuxième
ministère
nous sommes ici au conseil
constitutionnel dans la salle des
délibérations alors olivier abel d'abord
avant tout à quoi ça sert le conseil
constitutionnel le conseil
constitutionnel veille au respect de la
constitution et donc nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir il a été associé
aux grandes batailles qui ont conduit à
l'instauration de l'élection directe du
président et puis le conseil
constitutionnel veille particulièrement
à la régularité de l'élection
présidentielle c'est donc lui qui
surveille les parrainages décrète la
liste définitive des candidats
contrôle la régularité des élections
programmées résultats donc il est deux
fois impliqué par notre sujet à quand
remonte
dans la pensée du général de gaulle
l'idée de réformer la constitution est
de faire élire le président au suffrage
universel est ce que ces anciens
la première chose que l'on constate en
tout cas c'est que dans son grand
discours de bayeux en juin 1946 dans
lequel il expose pour la première fois
ses idées constitutionnel il n'est pas
question d'une élection du président de
la république par le peuple il ya
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
c'est que léon blum qui à l'époque est
le leader socialiste commente le texte
de bayeux est dit en commentant dans son
article du populaire il manque quelque
chose pour que ça tienne il manque
quelque chose pour que les idées
constitué du général de gaulle puissent
aboutir il faudrait élire le président
au suffrage universel donc ça c'est
assez extraordinaire en 46 si jal
capitule blum décrypte de gaulle
58 ne tiendra pas 162 et puis on va
l'oublier personne ne fera attention à
ça et le deuxième moment qui 1958 elle
est justement pourquoi en 58 au moment
ils font de la vème république il fait
la constitution pourquoi ce moment là
ils n'en profitent pas pour dire bon
gars et ils ont le président au suffrage
universel patrick rotman pour la même
raison parce que ce n'est pas possible
et donc on ne va pas s'embêter avec une
caisse noire quoi c'est pas possible ne
s'est pas possible pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que de gaulle est en train
de passer un compromis politique avec
les principaux partis de la quatrième
république sur la création d'une
république nouvelle et c'est parti ne
l'aurait pas accepté en 58 d'ailleurs
vous n'acceptez pas plus en 1962 et pour
une deuxième raison c'est qu'à l'époque
la décolonisation n'a prévu et que
privées de droit de vote les citoyens
les français d'afrique noire ou
d'algérie
serait scandaleux et leur accorder le
droit de vote serait leur remettre
l'élection du président les deux
solutions sont impossibles c'est tout à
fait impossible donc la question est
écarté est ce que nous révèle alain
peyrefitte c'est que de gaulle ya songé
avant l'attentât dupouy justement bien
jusqu'à maintenant penser c'était
l'histoire reçu c'est que c'était le
petit clamart l'attentât du petit
clamart qui avait déclenché le processus
l'envoya peyrefitte alain peyrefitte l'a
raconté dans son livre est la même dans
l'émission est dit que c'est une demi
heure avant il va en parler et il lui
dit on va refaire ça cet automne une
demi-heure avant le petit clamart alors
si le petit clamart n'est qu'un prétexte
qu'elles sont vraiment les raisons de
fond de gaulle à 60,2 de réformer la
constitution qui n'avait pendant 58 la
raison de fond c'est que ce comme c'est
bien expliqué d'ailleurs il craint
qu'une fois réglée la guerre d'algérie
on se débarrasse de lui de gaulle et on
se débarrasse des grandes innovations de
la vème république qu'on en revienne à
un jeu trop parlementaire qu'on en
revienne à des gouvernements trop soumis
aux partis qu'on n'accepte plus la
conduite de notre démocratie par un chef
on l'avait accepté que parce que c'était
de gaulle et la guerre d'algérie mais
que maintenant on en vienne à une espèce
de quatrième but et c'est pour éviter ça
pour que ses successeurs dirige le
pouvoir comme lui de gaulle l'a dirigé
qui veut faire l'arrivée dès qu'il fait
la révision constitutionnelle de
l'automne 1962 cette révision on l'a vu
à l'instant dans l'oeuf dans le film
soulève des objections mais 2,2 hors de
forme et de fond alors d'abord sur la
forme il ya ce fameux mots de gaston
maniabilité près du sénat ils parlent de
forfaiture alors vraiment est ce qu'il
ya eu
violation de la constitution ou le débat
une formidable bataille juridique parce
que la procédure normale de révision de
la constitution celle de l'article 89
impliqué qu'un projet du président passe
par l'assemblée nationale et par le
sénat et soit votée par l'assemblée
nationale et par le sénat a à l'évidence
ni l'assemblée nationale ni lé sénat
n'aurait accepté un tel renforcement du
pouvoir présidentiel donc de gaulle
s'est trouvé en quelque sorte quoi ainsi
par sa propre constitution jusqu'à ce
que l'idée
ils se disent mais je vais les
contourner je vais utiliser l'article
aux particuliers ce qui permet le
référendum direct mais c'est la sq ont
objecté les juristes l'article 11 on
l'attendait pour des lois ordinaires pas
pour réviser la constitution
extraordinaire bataille juridique
incroyable bataille juridique qui ne
concerne pas seulement les professeurs
mais qui concerne le conseil d'état qui
va donner un avis négatif et le général
de gaulle sera fureur contre la maison
d'à côté et conseil constitutionnel un
conseil constitutionnel le conseil
constitutionnel dans la navy secret mais
dans son avis secret cette instance qui
à l'époque était très sage très prudente
très gaulliste donne un avis négatif
alors dans un deuxième temps une fois le
référendum passé on va revenir ici et là
le conte séquentielle dans sa décision
dira qu'il peut pas contrôler avec ça va
piquer par l'aide approuvée par
référendum mais donc ça a été une
extraordinaire bataille juridique
maintenant c'est l'opposition sur le
fond là parce que là on voit aussi que
tous les partis sont contre écoutez sur
le fond droite et gauche sont
scandalisés à paris voulait très proche
du général d'abord parce que pour eux il
y a une il y a encore une identification
stricte entre démocratie et
parlementarisme pour eux
la seule forme démocratique sélection du
parlement donc déjà élire un président
est en soi antidémocratique pur style
c'est vraiment une vision très très
archaïque avec le recul ça sent très
étrange quand on a une vision parce que
dans les autres pays européens et
particulièrement dans le modèle qui est
le modèle anglais et bien c'est à
travers les élections des députés qu'on
fait le gouvernement parce que le seul
exemple c'est l'exemple américain qui
paraît un petit peu loufoque et puis
parce qu'il ya l'ombre de louis napoléon
bonaparte on juge toujours les rives
bonapartiste juste toujours les
constitutions non pas par rapport à
l'avenir mais par rapport au passé et on
se dit que ça va donner un lieu à la
naissance d'un pouvoir personnel et d'un
régime autoritaire bon c'est une
formidable bataille politique on l'a vu
la dent dans le sujet c'est les
arguments sont assez assez violent et de
gaulle est seul contre tous mais
finalement il gagne alors est ce qu'on
peut dire que plein à l'automne 62 c'est
vraiment un épisode crucial voir à
tournan du régime c'est une formidable
victoire extraordinaire victoire de rang
contre tout le monde de gaulle ne le
comprend pas quand il reste alain
peyrefitte nous dit déçu et même prostré
sur cette histoire des 47 % des inscrits
il en est même obligé françois goguel
qui est gaulliste et spécialiste des
questions électorales va produire une
note expliquant que 47 % des inscrits
qui ont voté oui en vérité ça fait plus
que ça parce que si on compte et il n'a
pas tort si on compte les gens qui sont
morts les femmes enceintes qui sont en
train d'accoucher c'est à dire
l'abstentionnisme obligé des gens
totalement empêché d'aller voter il y en
a au moins 3 4% et que donc on l'a
franchi les 50 et de gaulle du coup dit
ah bon alors donc il ya eu une
incompréhension par le général de
l'ampleur de sa victoire mais évidemment
il se reprend et puis la victoire est
doublé à l'élection législative c'est
coup double et c'est un coup double
beaucoup plus difficile parce que là
c'est contre les partis dans leur
terrain sur les dans les
circonscriptions sur leur territoire et
c'est là la wii wii perfidie la deuxième
mort de la quatrième donc la deuxième
naissance de la vème république en
tournant du régime alors maintenant on
va voir en face qu'il y avait la gauche
et l'histoire de la gauche de 58 à 65 et
pourquoi c'est comment c'est françois
mitterrand qui a été le candidat de la
gauche aux présidentielles de 65
en 1958 le retour au pouvoir du général
de gaulle a fait éclater les forces
politiques
la grande majorité du parti radical est
laid sefyu son secrétaire général guy
mollet en tête à rallier le général
à l'exception du parti communiste la
gauche est en morceaux disons qu'il n'y
avait pas de forces de gauche en dehors
du parti communiste qui était resté lui
une force contact et donc il y avait des
hommes comme ceux qui avaient refusé en
juin 58 le retour du général de gaulle
ceux qui s'étaient exprimés à
l'assemblée nationale pierre
mendès-france françois mitterrand
[Musique]
pierre mendès france est la personnalité
la plus estimée la véritable autorité
morale de cette gauche morcelée qui se
cherche françois mitterrand s'est lui
aussi dressé contre le général mais son
image est celle d'un ambitieux qui
suscite la méfiance de la nouvelle
gauche
étions prévenus qu'on mitterrand puis
cet homme qui avait appartenu à des
gouvernements de centre droit puis de
centre gauche
c'était pour nous
un peu un aventurier
tandis qu mahbès nous le respections
parce que c'était un homme de conviction
et son évolution à partir de 1956
l'avait amené de plus en plus vers des
positions de gauche mains d'aes puis
mitterrand décide d'adhérer au parti
socialiste autonome le ps à l'issue des
ces fillon est dirigée par alain savary
mais au ps à qui se transformera plus
tard en ps eut on ne veut pas de
mitterrand et les récuser pourquoi il va
récuser à cause du passé vichyssois et
c'est notre avis explicite que ça à l'as
alain savary et aussi parce que
peut-on avoir confiance dans un homme
qui a appartenu à tous les gouvernements
gouvernement laniel à des gouvernements
de droite qui a été avec mollet au temps
de la guerre d'algérie alors que ma
défense savary démissionné du
gouvernement mollet donc quelqu'un de
pas fiable et en plus le coût de la
francisque qui pour le compagnon de la
libération qui était alain savary et est
quelque chose de tout à fait
inadmissible
survient alors la sphère de
l'observatoire en octobre 59
le 16 octobre rentrant chez lui à une
heure du matin mitterrand se sent suivis
par une voiture il n'a que le temps
d'arrêter la sienne de sauter la grille
du jardin l'observatoire et de se
réfugier derrière les buissons sa 430 le
jouet mitraillé de cette balle de 9 mm
[Musique]
que pouvez vous nous dire
j'ai déjà déclaré
collègues de la presse
je ne dirai rien qui puisse ajouter au
désordre des esprits
il est logique de penser le climat de
passion politique créé par des
groupements extrémistes explique cette
affaire
l'émotion est considérable
la gauche unanime condamne l'attentât
mitterrand devient le héros du jour mais
une semaine plus tard coup de théâtre
[Musique]
un dénommé pesqué ancien député
d'extrême droite déclare à la presse que
cet attentat a été monté de toutes
pièces avec la complicité de mitterrand
pour preuve de ce qu'il avance pesqué
montre de lettres postées avant
l'attentât ouverte devant huissier qui
décrivent par le menu le déroulement
futur et l'attentât le piège est parfait
mitterrand a été dernier
[Musique]
convoqué chez le juge mitterrand crient
à la machination
il reconnaît que pesqué l'a bien
prévenues de l'imminence d'un attentat
il a gardé le silence à la demande de
pesqué pour sauvegarder la vie de ce
dernier les explications de françois
mitterrand ne convainquent pas tout le
monde
naturellement il est tombé dans un piège
naturellement il y avait une provocation
mais il a voulu si il a cru en la
sincérité de l'homme qui organisait ce
faux attentat il a dissimulé le fait à
ses amis il a commis l'imprudence de
prendre un verre avec l'auteur de
l'attentât trois jours après l'attentât
donc pour nous c'est de ce mitterrand
avait essayé de
d'apparaître comme l'homme le plus
détesté
par les partisans de l'algérie française
et donc il y aura une une réprobation
morale voilà ce qu'est cet homme nous
avions raison de penser que c'était un
aventurier nous avons été séduits mais
nous avions tort et ça c'est resté
longtemps
chez les gens venus de la nouvelle
gauche et bien entendu chez mitterrand
qui n'a pas pardonné un certain nombre
d'hommes
de l'avoir critiqué au condamné à
l'époque
le 25 novembre à une très large majorité
le sénat vote la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de mitterrand qui est
inculpé le 8 décembre sur le plan
judiciaire la sphère s'enlise pendant
trois ans mitterrand se tait
françois mitterrand a montré cette
époque là une volonté un ressort tout à
fait extraordinaire alors qu'il était
abandonné la plupart de ses amis mais il
a traversé pendant plusieurs semaines ou
plusieurs mois autour de cette histoire
une crise morale très très profondes et
dont il s'est une fois qu'il a pu garder
pour lui et dont il ne s'est ouvert qu'à
quelques amis proches
en 1962 françois mitterrand retrouve son
siège de député de la nièvre après 7
opposés à la réforme de la constitution
[Musique]
françois mitterrand qui avait combattu
cette réforme a quand même une fois
qu'elle était d'adopter compris très
vite que c'était probablement le seul
moyen de faire élire un président de la
république de gauche parce que si l'on
en était resté à ce qui était autrefois
le collège électoral qui est disait le
président la république qui ressemble un
peu au collège sénatoriales d'ailleurs
été un collège de notables il n'y avait
aucune chance jamais que la gauche
puisse l'emporter et françois mitterrand
a compris que cette réforme à laquelle
il avait été hostile mais à partir du
moment où elles existent et il fallait
entrer dans le jeu et en tirer tous les
avantages possibles et c'est à partir de
là si vous voulez que il a commencé à
préparer ce qui devenait on devait
devenir ensuite sa première candidature
en 1965
mitterrand cherche un second souffle il
écrit un violent pamphlet contre de
gaulle le coup d'état permanent
la gauche se cherche et des bas c'est
l'époque des clubs mitterrand grâce à
charles hernu aura bientôt le sien la
convention des institutions
républicaines
un autre club le club jean moulin lens
fin 63 l'opération monsieur x appuyé par
l'inventif directeur de l'express
jean-jacques servan-schreiber
monsieur x doit être le candidat aux
présidentielles de 65 d'une grande
fédération regroupant centristes et
socialistes
très vite le canard enchaîné révèle que
ce monsieur x pourrait bien être l'homme
au masque de fer
gaston defferre se déclare
officiellement le 18 décembre 63
françois mitterrand a soutenu très
loyalement le la tentative de gaston
defferre avec monsieur x mais il n'y a
jamais cru il n'y a jamais cru et je me
souviens très bien de conversation avec
lui à l'époque il était convaincu que
gaston defferre s'était engagé dans une
voie erronée c'est à dire la recherche
d'une alliance avec le centre alors
qu'en réalité le poids du parti
communiste peser si lourd à l'époque que
s'il n'y avait pas un minimum d'entente
avec le parti communiste il n'y avait
aucune chance que président de gauche
puisse m'en est de faire la finit par le
constater par abandonner sa tentative la
grande fédération échoue le 17 juin 65
le 25 juin
gaston defferre retire sa candidature
à cinq mois des élections la gauche n'a
plus de candidat
au début de l'été la voix est presque
libre pour françois mitterrand
nous a fait comprendre qu'il était prêt
à maintenant à se lancer dans cette
compétition tout à fait nouvelle et est
un peu inconnu que représente l élection
c'est vrai l'universel et explicite tu
disais oui oui il était explicite il
pose et même trois conditions pour être
candidat et ses trois conditions qu'ils
nous charger en quelque sorte de
répandre autour de nous et surtout
auprès des intéressés c'était d'une part
d'avoir l'accord de pierre mendès-france
deuxièmement d'avoir le soutien
explicite de la sfio c'est à dire de guy
mollet à l'époque et troisièmement que
le parti communiste ne présente pas de
candidats c'est à dire
ce rallye en quelque sorte à sa
candidature telles étaient les trois
conditions
claude estier est chargé des contacts
avec les communistes
à la mi-août waldeck rochet le prévient
que le pc ne fera pas obstacle à la
candidature mitterrand
depuis 1960 les minoritaires de partout
se sont regroupés au sein du ps eut
petit et déchiré dans ce laboratoire en
ébullition de la nouvelle gauche ont
fait la moue devant mitterrand le psu
qui étaient divisés d'intendance là
c'est trouver parfaitement uni et nous
sommes année je ne sais combien de fois
va mendès-france rue du pont c'est
collignon et est quasiment enfin
moralement le genou en terre nous
l'avons su plier d'être d'être le
candidat et nous n'avons pas réussi à le
convaincre
et quand on lui disait mais alors si
c'est pas vous ça risque d'être
mitterrand chose affreuse mais non vous
exagérez
il a toujours été loyal à mon égard je
n'ai pas en plein de l'huile a des
qualités et ses
retours des vacances françois mitterrand
est décidé à forcer le destin
les trois conditions posées soutien de
pierre mendès france de guy mollet et de
waldeck rochet sont remplies il peut
compter également sur gaston defferre 9
septembre il annonce sa candidature
[Musique]
j'étais avec lui ce jour là nous étions
quelques-uns en train de déjeuner dans
un restaurant qui n'existe plus à
montparnasse qui s'appelait la palette
et à un moment donné après ce donc nous
avoir convaincu que que tout était tout
était en place pour sa candidature
françois mitterrand a déchiré la nappe
en papier et a écrit une déclaration de
quelques lignes qui nous a chargé le
communiqué l afp un certain nombre de
gens et je me souviendrai toujours que
la postière bas m'a dit eh bien voulu le
souhait très bonne chance
à 16 heures l'information tombe sur les
téléscripteurs françois mitterrand est
candidat à la présidence de la
république
le nouvel observateur de sensibilité
nouvelle gauche boucle ce jour là nous
avons eu donc pour la confection de ce
numéro un débat doc turne dont j'ai
gardé le souvenir en partant d'une
maquette de la une qui fut était
mitterrand jamais et qui s'est terminée
par mitterrand pourquoi
olivier duhamel après 58 après le retour
au pouvoir le général de gaulle on voit
bien que la gauche non communiste à deux
leaders possibles potentiels françois
mitterrand et pierre mendès france ont
des france à quelques longueurs d'avancé
pourtant en 65 c'est françois mitterrand
qui sera candidat alors pourquoi
question simple réponse complexe ce qui
est assez extraordinaire en effet c'est
que
d'un côté on va avoir l'obstination du
grand homme dans l'erreur en termes
politiques à ces monnaies strauss et
d'autre part
l'ascension de celui qui est décrié
comme un aventurier
alors ça c'est françois mitterrand ainsi
qu'aux métiers on a compris je crois
alors demandés seront aussi fait des
erreurs auxquelles la france reste
d'abord mendès-france
comme est d'une certaine manière la même
erreur que de vos erreurs symétrique de
2 relate an de l'élection présidentielle
et on l'a vu durant sa réaction au
référendum on le reverra après l'espèce
de grands élans unanimiste de
rassemblement du peuple derrière le chef
et c'est ce qu'il veut mads s'attend à
ce que l'élection présidentielle
produisent un grand rassemblement
unanimiste derrière le chef et c'est ce
qu'il craint
alors que l'élection présidentielle va
rien faire de tout ça elle va faire ce
que produit une élection démocratique
concurrentiel c'est à dire de la
division de l'affrontement une majorité
opposition est donc déjà il ya cette
erreur de ma vie c'est ma vie ensuite il
ya son refus très profond de la vème
république sa conviction que la vème
république est un régime illégitime et
régime précaire fragile qui va
disparaître c'est un refus sur le faut
oui c'est une deuxième erreur ce qui est
une erreur dans l'évaluation des faux et
puis alors la troisième attitude et de
crispation sur les principes
de l'attachement aux principes si on
veut dire gentiment qui fait que
derrière toutes les sollicitations il va
refuser et al'inverse françois
mitterrand lui quelles qualités il les
montre alors
le génie politique dans l'intelligence
de la fosse et du génie politique dans
les cours du la critique dans la
conduite des opérations dans
l'intelligence de la chose parce que lui
comprend ni compan que l'élection
présidentielle ne sais pas ce vaste
scénario des ministres où il va pas dans
le mur s'il cherche un candidat mais qui
va au contraire la tête il a écrit
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus tard que des 62
dès qu'il a vu que la réforme est
adoptée il avait dit ils avaient compris
qu'il serait candidat lui qu'on dit
souvent que c'est c'est l'occasion pour
lui françois mitterrand d'être
réhabilité de reprendre la main
reprendre le jeu que c'est l'occasion
pour la gauche de se reconstruire de se
restructurer de se transformer et que ça
va être l'occasion de l'alternance au
pouvoir
petit désaccord avec claude estier quand
il dit jamais son élection directe un
président de la république aurait été
lui à gauche mais sans élection directe
l'enjeu était pas tellement la
présidence de la république c'est que
avec la présence de la république plus
que l'élection d'un président de gauche
on va permettre l'alternance que la
gauche véritablement exerce le pouvoir
et sa françois mitterrand en à
l'illumination des 62 66 ce sont les
raisons profondes est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il ya aussi des red est un ressort
intime ressort personnel on a insisté
dans le sujet sur la paire
l'observatoire est ce que sans la faire
l'observatoire france mi temps aurait
été candidat en soit 2,5
les grands hommes politiques ont besoin
dans la conquête du pouvoir d'être mues
par une passion et d'être mais aussi par
la volonté de résister à l'adversité
c'est vrai qu'on dira plus tard de
georges pompidou que sans les attaques
dont il avait été l'objet pts qui
n'auraient pas eu la force mais c'est
très similaire et d'une certaine manière
on peut dire la même chose pour françois
mitterrand mais enfin ce qui est
frappant quand même c'est de toute façon
à quel point lui d'un animal politique
bien doux et fort l'astucieux par
exemple osé imposer le soutien de mendes
le soutien de la sfp you et la corde et
communiquera tous cas ils voient bien
les trois bonnes conditions à remplir
vous des voix il les imposent les
obtient les obtiens ça c'est aussi parce
qu'il est aidé par les autres acteurs
politiques qui eux ne comprennent pas
qu'ils ne pensent que l'élection
présidentielle est catastrophique et qui
donc reste en-deça de la main et puis
aussi à côté de cette audace là où il
faut être prudent il est prudent par
exemple il ne m'est pas comme préalable
la transformation des organisations à la
différence de gaston defferre qui pose
un préalable si on ne fait pas la grande
fédération je n'y vais pas mais
mitterrand nommé passé à givet et après
une fois les voix engrangées je pourrais
faire les transformations nécessaires on
va voir maintenant la campagne du
premier tour parce que le jour même où
françois mitterrand annonce sa
candidature le 9 septembre bat général
de gaulle tient une conférence de presse
ce n'est pas absolument une coïncidence
je vous et vous aide à vous monsieur le
président pouvez vous nous dire si vous
comptez vous présenter à l'élection du 5
décembre
je vous réponds tout de suite que vous
le soir et je vous le promets avant deux
mois
si donc de gaulle se présente les
résultats du 5 décembre deviennent plus
difficiles à atteindre pour les
candidats qui se présentent contre lui
vous dirai donc mauvaise nouvelle pour
vous bonne nouvelle mesdames et
messieurs cela prouve que le régime ait
frappé à ma mais moi je peux attendre
quant à votre avis le général à est il
pris sa décision se présenter par est
évident d'après les notes que j'avais
prise que sa décision était tout à fait
arrêtée avant le 1er juillet et qu'il
voulait se laisser suffisamment de temps
pour voir les choses évoluer et que
surtout ils voulaient pas que la
campagne dure trop longtemps il estimait
comme moi c'était bien 4 novembre pour
le 5 septembre le 5 décembre qui était
le premier tour ça faisait 31 jours
c'était suffisant aujourd'hui
je crois devoir
poursuivre
de quels efforts il s'agit
mais convaincu qu actuellement
c'est le mieux pour servir la france
lorsque de gaulle annonce sa candidature
cela fait plus d'un mois que mitterrand
bat la campagne lors de sa première
conférence de presse le 21 septembre le
fait lutetia il a appelé au
rassemblement de toute la gauche sans
exclusive et développer les sept options
de son programme
lors d'une deuxième conférence de presse
le 17 novembre les dirigeants du pc
l'est ces filles sont au premier rang
à paris et en province les meetings se
multiplient
[Musique]
c'était complètement artisanale nous
n'avions extrêmement peu de moyens mais
on a constaté très vite que si j'ose
dire là la mayonnaise prenait et que le
premier meeting qui se sont organisés
rassembler quand même des foules
considérables
les gens qui qui se reconnaissaient dans
la gauche et et qui avait retrouvé à une
certaine espérance
dans cette idée même et dans cette
concrétisation séoul et d'un
rassemblement de la gauche qui
paraissaient hors de portée depuis tant
d'années
dans la course à l'elysée d'autres
prétendants sont entrés en piste
jean louis tixier vignancour candidat de
l'extrême droite
pierre marcilhacy un géant centriste
marcel barbu candidats farfelus
et enfin jean le camus et héritier de la
démocratie chrétienne les grands
défenseurs de l'idée européenne
la seule qu'elle république
refuse les moyens de ses propres
objectifs dont certains et je vais le
dire avec plate et qui juste
entre tous ces champions le parti
radical balance
il apprécie la porter la valeur de la
candidature de jean lecanuet
mais
fidèle à sa tradition de partis de
gauche
il recommande à ses membres
de soutenir la candidature de françois
mitterrand
la grande nouveauté de ces élections et
la campagne officielle à la télévision
les français qui depuis des années voyez
sur leur petit écran étroitement
contrôlés toujours les mêmes visages
toujours les mêmes images découvre des
têtes inconnues
celle des responsables de l'opposition
alain peyrefitte ministre de
l'information est chargé de réglementer
les temps d'antenne des candidats alors
j'avais envisagé deux hypothèses
celle de l'égalité de traitement entre
opposition et majorité
c'est à dire que le ou les candidats
d'opposition et tue la moitié du temps
la radio comme à la télévision
et
le ou les candidats
au nom de la majorité sortante
aurait la moitié du temps
et venez râle a balayé cette hypothèse
profit de l'autre hypothèse qui était
que chacun des candidats quels qu'ils
soient aurait le même temps de parole il
y aura donc pour les candidats
quatre séries complètes de 14 minutes
deux séries complètes de 28 minutes et
une série complète de huit minutes
et bien je vous propose de changer de
vitesse de prendre un autre rythme un
autre élan bref je vous propose pour la
france un plan de progrès mais je le
gagne des plans de progrès alors je vous
demanderai de no1 indiqué les grandes
orientations
vous avez raison
eh bien monsieur mitterrand si vous
voulez je crois qu'il faut en arriver à
haute définition
est ce que le mot de gauche encore un
sens aujourd'hui est-ce que ça qu'est ce
que ça veut bien pouvoir dire gauche en
1965 la gauche voyez-vous cherche
d'abord la justice et veux que la
justice établisse un nouvel ordre la
droite elle elle veut que elle veut
l'autre elle veut que la justice
garantis cela c'est toute la différence
pourquoi les gaullistes non je ne parle
pas de général mais non pas du tout
utilisé des arguments contre contre le
candidat mitterrand n'a pas été question
de la de la francisque de la paire
l'observatoire qui était toute fraîche
toute récente et aucun des arguments de
campagne justement n'a été utilisé par
sea n'a pas voulu
il nous l'a interdit
à la sortie d'un conseil des ministres à
de mes collègues ne dirai pas le nom il
le dira s'il veut
a demandé à suivre le vénérable en même
temps que moi comme nous le faisons
d'habitude pour notre tête à tête et il
a dit van mens général
votre principal adversaire un des cas
c'est mitterrand
il ya un formidable arguments contre lui
c'est ce qui s'est passé à
l'observatoire nous allons dossier le
dossier d hier a été largement ouvert au
sénat puisque le sénat contrairement à
toutes ses habitudes à lever l'immunité
parlementaire de mitterrand il suffit de
rendre ça public et se lie portera un
coup dont il se relèvera pas
eh bien elle général de gaulle a répondu
non je ne ferai pas ça et ne le fait pas
je ne ferai pas la politique des boules
puantes
et ajouté en regardant bien mon collègue
il ne faut pas
insulter la fonction pour le cas où il
viendrait à l'occuper
mitterrand lui tient revenir sur cette
affaire de l'observatoire dès le premier
jour j'ai dit c'est une machination
et dans le fond aujourd'hui vous en
parle
rien ne trouble notamment la différence
mais ma sérénité et s'il advenait on en
reparle j'en serais heureux
car je pas qu'il me serait aisé
désormais de faire la démonstration
qu'on me refuse
le général certain de son prestige
auprès des français n'a sorti qu'une
seule affiche de campagne et à la fin
novembre comme ils l'avaient décidé il
n'a toujours pas parlé à télévision
j'ai parlé de la campagne du général de
gaulle à d'après les déclarations que
vous avez pas d'hier ils sentent qu'ils
ne doivent pas faire compagne m'a fait
savoir qu'il ne compte pas utiliser tout
son temps de parole ne se contentera de
parler brièvement vers la fin de la
campagne le suppose il est suffisamment
connue des français et il n'a pas besoin
de se faire connaître deux
mais fin novembre à quinze jours du
scrutin les sondages catastrophiques
pour de gaulle prévoit le ballottage de
66% au début novembre qui sont descendus
à 46% le 24 novembre tandis que
mitterrand est à 28 et le calme et à 14%
brusquement on a vu ce capital virtuel
de voit fondre m'effondre à toute
vitesse au fur et à mesure que la
campagne se dérouler et que ses
adversaires l'attaqué
et le général ne voulais pas utiliser
son temps de parole il faisait les
français me connaissent bien ils n'ont
pas besoin que je fasse quand
alors un jour je vais écouter mon
général une campagne c'est comme un
match de boxe
on reçoit des coups et en donne si vous
vous contentez nord se voir si vous n'en
donnait aucun mais vous serez est ko
avant la fin de la partie
et il faut absolument que vous parliez
alors il a accepté en grinçant des dents
de parler une fois les pensées ont enfin
réappris le chemin des urnes et le
nombre des abstentionnistes est descendu
à un pourcentage jamais encore atteint
15%
marcel barbu détient 1% des voix pierre
marcil à 6 1 5 7 %
tixier vignancour 5%
jean lecanuet 16%
françois mitterrand atteint 32% ce qui
dépasse de loin toutes les prévisions et
enfin avec 44% des voix de gaulle et
bien en ballottage
il était très surpris on était tous
surpris du résultat est surpris et
heureux et je me souviens que dans la
nuit même mitterrand a dit bowman
maintenant il faut travailler au second
tour d'abord on je le répète on ne
croyait pas l'idée d'un second tour mais
ça à transformer complètement le sens
même de la campagne parce que du coup ça
devenait une formidable
projection pour l'avenir et pas
seulement à un témoignage d'un moment
quoi ce même soir du 5 décembre georges
pompidou louis joxe et alain peyrefitte
téléphone à de gaulle qui est à colombes
et à sion là j'ai trouvé du fils du
général de gaulle très abattu
très
déprimé
en face d'une catastrophe qui
n'imaginait pas parce qu'il considérait
que depuis 1940 il avait rendu
suffisamment de services à la patrie
pour que les français votent pour lui en
majorité la première fois qu'il se
présentait à eux et dont j'ai essayé de
remonter le moral en lui disant que
naturellement quinze jours plus tard ça
allait changer et
je pas convaincu du tout quand vous
récusez a raccroché j'ai raccroché plein
inquiétudes craignais s'ils ne
reviennent pas que l'omb et je chronique
n ont même pas
nous sommes toujours en conseil
constitutionnel dans le grand salon où
sont proclamés les résultats des
élections olivier duhamel avec la
campagne du premier tour on voit que les
français découvrent une élection qui est
nouvelle pour eux et là tout au début du
film on a vu alain peyrefitte confère un
petit un petit scoop une petite
révélation nous a annoncé que le général
de gaulle avait pris sa décision de se
présenter le 1er juillet or il fait
durer le suspense quatre mois c'est déjà
une astuce de campagne voilà c'est déjà
c'est une des premières découvertes
c'est que dans cette élection on
s'adresse directement au peuple et qu'on
ne le fait pas de la même manière si on
est disons chef en exercice président
premier ministre ou si on est challenger
si on est candidat de l'opposition le
candidat de l'opposition a besoin de
challenger a besoin de partir plus tôt
de labourer la campagne de labour et
donc il fait une campagne de meeting
alors que l'homme d'état en exercice
peut feindre le suspense différer son
entrée en campagne le faire sur le mode
de l'annonce très officielle comme une
allocution dans la camp même modèle
goulien qui laissera quelques traces par
la suite et qui est une des premières
renseignements de l'époque alors ce qui
est vraiment nouveau dans cette campagne
c'est pour la première fois la
télévision va jouer un rôle il faut
d'ailleurs se replacer dans le contexte
de l'époque il n'y avait pas de
magazines d'information et où
l'opposition de s'exprimer à peu près
jamais à la télévision donc là c'est la
nouveauté ce qui est très intéressant et
qu'on apprend dans deux avec le
témoignage d'alain peyrefitte
c'est l'extraordinaire contradiction
entre un mode de décision
incroyablement autoritaire arbitraire et
une décision elle même très démocratique
songez donc que c'est le général de
gaulle candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui a choisi tout seul
quelle serait la règle du jeu pour la
campagne à la télévision quand on y
pense on voit à quel point là on vivait
dans une pré démocratie mais miracle
qu'est ce qu'ils aient choisi la
solution la plus démocratique il choisit
de donner à chaque candidat le même
temps de parole marcel
d'armure le candidat des coupes est égal
à charles de gaulle président de la
république française à l'époque du coup
la campagne va être plus égalitaire
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui puisqu'il
n'existe pas comme un produit des
chaînes de télévision privées il
n'existe pas de distinction grands
candidats je signale au passage il n'y a
aucune image de cette campagne dire
qu'on a cherché vainement les meeting de
françois mitterrand de jean lecanuet et
c'est ça n'existe pas il ya pas été ou
sera pas été filmé par la télévision et
il reste aucune trace et journaux
télévisés de l'époque mais on voit aussi
que de gaulle sous estime enfin on
retrouve l'espèce d'erreurs d'analysé du
général sur ce qu'ils inventent c'est ça
qui est formidable parce que lui il va
même pas utilisé son temps de parole les
hommes font l'histoire mais savent pas
histoire qu'il fond de gronde pense
qu'il n'a pas besoin d'utiliser cette
entente parle peyrefitte nous dit pas ce
qu'il est déjà connu si c'était ça le
problème je veux dire c'est une élection
fondamentalement démocratique
comme chaque candidat se font des
français attendent de chaque candidat
qu'il participe à la bataille et de
gaulle pendant longtemps le méprisent et
puis on voit qu'au fur et à mesure je
dirais et que je dis que la campagne
avance on a un drôle de plus en plus
démocratique de plus en plus jovial de
plus en plus comique
qu'ils prennent certaines distances donc
ça c'est aussi extraordinaire l'autre
découverte qui va de pair avec ce qu'on
peut dire c'est la découverte des
sondages voilà c'est la première fois
qu'ils jouent un rôle important et c'est
d'ailleurs eux qui ne sonne le tocsin
s'il ya vraiment quand il annonce que le
général est en ballottage que chez les
gaullistes c'est l'affolement ça va être
très important pour la suite de
l'histoire c'est à dire qu après coup on
va s'apercevoir que les sondages disent
juste et donc on va croire aux sondages
et donc les sondages vont prendre la
place que l'on connaît dans notre
histoire politique mais à l'époque
personne n'y croit personne n'y croit à
preuve la stupeur du ballottage à preuve
à nouveau cette déprime du général c'est
le soir du 5 vraiment on se rend compte
qu'à ballottage c'est le soir du 5 qu'on
se rend compte que la france est un pays
démocratique normal et que son
présidentielle est une élection ouverte
et qu'on a beau être un très grand homme
d'état comme de gros ont fait un score
somme toute banale enfin banal à
l'époque il était terrifié aujourd'hui
encore coût de candidats que vous serez
content oui très content de faire 44 %
un soir de premier tourné à l'époque
c'est le choc et vous avez noté c'est
aussi le choc dont l'opposition qui n'y
croyaient pas alors ça c'est comme la
surprise c'est le ballottage mais ça
veut dire que la campagne joue un rôle
et s'il ya eu ce ballottage c'est parce
que les deux principaux candidats
adversaires du général françois
mitterrand pour la gauche et jean le cam
les pressantes on fait une très bonne
campagne c'est le peut-être le dernier
enseignement dès la première
présidentielle et qui va se retrouver
après à chaque élection présidentielle
en tout cas jusqu'à la 6ème que nous
vivons en ce moment qui est
l'extraordinaire importance de la
campagne électorale on donne à
l'électeur 1 3 le droit de vote les
lecteurs aiment ça les lecteurs s'empare
de son droit et l'utilisent il change
d'avis en campagne quand il trouve un
candidat mauvais il élimine quand il
trouve un candidat bon il le soutient et
on accepte quand ils hésitent y a du
recul on a cet extraordinaire montée
c'est très belle campagne de jean
lecanuet qui est dans un espace
politique restreint trouve sa place on a
le succès trop sous mitterrand au delà
de toutes les espérances
on a des mouvements de campagne
électorale très important et on
retrouvera 169 en 74 ans 81 88 bref les
lecteurs aiment choisir son président
maintenant le duel du second tour
pour le second tour des présidentielles
fac leurs pensées et pancartes à
l'américaine monsieur françois
mitterrand a jeté toutes ses forces dans
la bataille
quant au général de gaulle s'il n'a
présider lui-même aucun meeting il a été
soutenu devant l'opinion par ses
ministres contrairement à ce qui s'était
passé lors du premier tour l'atmosphère
des grands rassemblements politiques a
reparu au palais des sports où avec une
ardeur passionnés monsieur andré malraux
a mené une des contre attaques les plus
percutantes contre le candidat de
l'opposition
mais c'est sans doute le duel des deux
candidats dans les champs claude
multiples des appartements qui a
finalement infléchi la balance des
pourcentages
j'aimerais que vous précisiez la façon
dont vous les entendez dont voulait
conserver ces notions de gauche et de
droite
la france c'est tout à la fois c'est
tous les français
c'est pas la gauche la france c'est pas
la droite la france
naturellement les français comme de tout
temps ils ont eu
à 109 courant il y à l'éternel courant
du mouvement
qui va aux réformes qui va au changement
qui est naturellement nécessaire et puis
aussi courant de l'ordre la règle de la
tradition qui est aussi nécessaire si
avec tout ça qu'on fait la france
il y a pour ce qui est de la france qui
se passe dans une maison
la maîtresse de maison la ménagère
elle veut avoir un aspirateur d'avoir un
frigidaire
elle me voir une machine à laver
et même si c'est possible qu'on ait une
tôt
ça c'est le mouvement
en même temps elle veut pas que son mari
saheb embaucher tout pas que les garçons
on met les pieds sur la table et que les
filles en attend pas la nuit
changer l'ordre
et la ménagère veut le progrès mais ne
veut pas la pagaille
et bien c'est vrai aussi pour la france
il faut le progrès il faut pas la
pagaille
or le régime des partis cenap ailleurs
non ce n'est pas vrai vous n'aurez pas à
choisir dimanche entre leur régime
actuel et celui des partis le régime
actuel c'est celui d'un homme seul et
quand viendra pour lui l'heure de partir
il vous livrera au successeur inconnu
que vous désignera un clan une faction
pire qu'un parti cet entourage
syndicats anonyme d'intérêt et d'être ig
je ne suis pas l'homme d'un parti
je ne suis pas l'homme d'une coalition
de partis je suis le candidat de toute
la gauche de la gauche généreuse de la
gauche interne elle qui avant moi qui
après mois a été sera la valeur
permanente de notre pape
quand j'avais 25 ans je me suis évadé
d'allemagne j'aime la liberté
j'ai rejoint le général de gaulle à
londres et alger
l'extrême droite avait une une si forte
contre de gaulle
jerry française prades et
abandonner une haine si forte contre de
gaulle qu'elle était prête à soutenir
n'importe qui
qui s'opposerait à de gaulle donc se
ravit - était un ralliement de colère
contre donc pas un ralliement à mi
terrain ni un ralliement la gauche le
nombre d abstention est resté ce qu'il
fut lors du premier tour c'est à dire le
plus bas 15% qui ait jamais été observé
dans une élection française on peut dire
que toutes les catégories sociales ont
tenu à accomplir leur devoir électoral
cette participation massive peut donc
être aujourd'hui considéré comme un
véritable plébiscite en faveur du
suffrage universel pour le choix du
président de la république et au soir de
ce 19 décembre
l'atmosphère de la capitale confirmé la
passion suscitée dans tous les secteurs
de l'opinion par cette grande
consultation
[Musique]
mais le suspense fut de très courte
durée et les premiers résultats les
prévisions dégâts le français se
trouvaient exactement vérifier
un peu plus tard le ministère de
l'intérieur établissait que monsieur
françois mitterrand avait obtenu
quelques 10 millions 500 mille voix et
le général de gaulle 12 millions 800
mille avec une majorité de 55% le
président de la république inaugurera le
8 janvier un nouveau septennat
[Musique]
pour le suspense terrible qui durait
depuis le début de l'émission est
terminée c'est bien le général de gaulle
qui a été élu ou réélu le 19 décembre
1965 alors olivier duhamel on va essayer
de tirer quelques leçons de ce scrutin
historique d'abord sur un plan politique
on voit c'est la gauche à son leader
oui les leçons politiques et
institutionnelles s'entrecroisent à
gauche la première leçon c'est
l'émergence d'un nouveau leader françois
mitterrand c'est donc le signe que
l'élection présidentielle peut être un
vecteur pour l'apparition de nouveaux
leaders politiques c'est une leçon qui
va être
comprise par les français mais en même
temps on est dans un pays dans lequel du
coup les leaders à stature
présidentielle reste très longtemps
finalement l'émission de ce soir elle
ponctue à sa manière trente années de
l'histoire de france et sur 1965 mais ce
qui se produit là va marquer notre
aventure politique pendant 30 ans qui
est que l'on peut dire dans le français
mitterrand cette élection 65,7 débute sa
longue marche vers l'elysée ah oui oui
bien entendu c'est le début de
l'occupation de nos positions très
importantes dans la vie politique
française par françois mitterrand alors
derrière le leader va se produire aussi
un rassemblement c'est-à-dire la
fédération de la gauche démocrate et
socialiste donc les forces politiques de
gauche vont pouvoir se regrouper à
stratégie niang à gauche dans la dans
leur ont donc d'abord le regroupement de
tout ce qui existait entre
l'adroit la commune au centre et les
communistes alors que c'était éparpille
éclaté depuis de très nombreuses années
et puis vous avez raison troisièmement
une stratégie la stratégie d'union de la
gauche
tout ceci cela dit va connaître des
progrès et des reculs va pas être
l'objet d'un mouvement linéaire mais
l'élection présidentielle de 65 a été
grand accélérateur a été nommé biais de
cette histoire même si donc d'autres
élections présidentielles pense par
exemple à la deuxième celle de 1969 au
pouvoir au contraire su faire subir des
reculs hi media publie de nouvelles
progressions alors à droite quelles
conséquences politiques je crois que la
première conséquence à droite c'est la
banalisation du général de gaulle le
général de gaulle est devenu un homme
politique presque comme les eaux et son
piédestal il descend du piédestal alors
c'est à la fois décevant eu parfois
déprimant pour lui c'est en même temps
une forme de vrai succès pour lui parce
que du coup son régime devient plus
important que lui-même son parti devient
aussi important que lui-même le
gaullisme va survivre au général de
gaulle la vème république va survivre au
général de gaulle dont il ya là quelque
chose de personnellement peut-être
difficile mais au fond quant à
l'accomplissement de son oeuvre qui est
plutôt de l'ordre du succès profond
notons enfin à droite que grâce à la
performance de jean lecanuet il va y
avoir le maintien assez durable d'un
centrisme d'opposition le centrisme
d'opposition ne sera définitivement
absorbé que par l'élection
présidentielle de 1974 il va y avoir
deux étapes 69 duhamel et fontanes et
kiraly pompidou et 74 lecanu et kiraly
giscard et une fois de plus c'est
l'élection présidentielle qui est le
moment de la transformation des
relations entre les forces politiques
c'est donc très important malgré ce
cette persistance d'un centre de
position c'est quand même la marche vers
la bipolarisation de la vie politique on
voit bien que l'élection présidentielle
produits comme automatiquement ce que
les savants appelle l'aide aux fins d
une politologue appelle la
bipolarisation c'est à dire pas le
regroupement deux camps pourquoi parce
qu'au jour décisif au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle il faut voter
dupont ou durand il ya le choix qu'entre
du pot et durant martin n'existe plus
c'est un choix à 2 blanc ou noir donc
bipolaire et ceci pèse sur les forces
politiques et en effet va être un
accélérateur de la bipolarisation dans
la vème république alors maintenant
voyons les leçons plusieurs
institutionnels dont la première s'est
peut-être quand même que les français
j'allais dire le plébiscite frère de
kyle adoptent cette réforme de manière
massive
oui tout à fait je dirais que l'idée
directrice ici est celle de
l'irréversibilité alors d'abord
l'irréversibilité de l'élection
présidentielle on a donné ce pouvoir aux
françaises et aux français ils ne sont
pas près de se laisser enlever cette
prérogative et pourtant il ya beaucoup
d'hommes politiques et de femmes
politiques et encore aujourd'hui qui au
fond d'eux mêmes idées les mêmes
préférerait que vous choisissez pas le
chef comme ça surtout quand ils n'ont
pas de chance d'être élu chef et qui
trouvent que c'est quelque chose
d'anormal la donne en france et vivra
comme une conquête démocratique ils
vivent ça comme un grand moment
politique comme une magnifique
corrida avec mise à mort comme un vrai
enjeu ils vivent ça comme un choix
démocratique personnel ils n'ont pas
envie de le perdre deuxièmement c'est
l'irréversibilité du présidentialisme
français c'est-à-dire de la puissance du
président de la république sur
l'ensemble des institutions du rouleau
directeur du plie on a un public qui
n'est pas seulement un arbitre mais qui
est également le responsable politique
sauf cas particuliers cohabitation et ça
c'est l'élection présidentielle qui
fabrique et refabrique qui maintient et
entretient le présidentialisme français
qui paraît à cet égard assez
irréversible est ce que c'est le modèle
patron de cette façon la vie politique
au point que maintenant tout est
conditionné par par cette élection
présidentielle certains défauts certains
travers qui avaient été relevés à
l'époque par pierre mendès france par
exemple apparaissent peut-être avec le
recul du temps disons que le corollaire
c'est que ça entretient le drogba
parlons franchement nettement le
monarchisme de france elle est le
monarchiste de nos moeurs politiques que
même il est probable que ce monarchisme
s'est aggravée au fil des années et que
il conviendrait peut-être de réfléchir
comment dans une démocratie moderne
inventer des contrepoids et surtout des
exigences quant à nos moeurs et
peut-être même vigilance si vite pour ne
pas laisser ces accompagnements
monarchique prospérer comme il le faut
mais il reste que malgré ce prix à payer
ce prix à payer qui n'est pas
inéluctable encore une fois on peut
peut-être cherché à modifier par
d'autres biais tout en gardant l'acquis
de l'élection présidentielle il reste
que l'élection présidentielle est
vraiment le moment décisif de notre vie
démocratique et cela sans interruption
depuis 1965 trente ans après on est à
dire la vème république est vraiment
enraciné et que cette élection était
adopté la vème république a été
définitivement consacré il y a trente
ans merci olivier duhamel pour terminer
cette émission comme d'habitude des
livres beaucoup de livres d'abord les
vôtres vous avez consacré votre pèse
la gauche la vème république sur un plan
institutionnel d'ailleurs vous étiez
toute l'évolution de la gauche sur la
bible x est publié aux puf collection
quadrige la gauche et la vème république
olivier duhamel et là vous avez publié
un gros pavé droit constitutionnel et
politique au seuil dont qui montre très
bien je crois qu'ils m'aiment pour les
ignares qui comprennent rien aux droits
constitutionnels comme moi le rapport
entre ce que la politique l'histoire est
là des constitutions non seulement en
france mais aussi dans le reste du monde
c'est publié au seuil alors on a vu pas
mal alain peyrefitte dans cette émission
il a publié à quelques semaines c'était
de gaulle éditions de fallois fayard lit
tout à fait intéressant et même
passionnant parce que bourré de
révélations est formidable il ne
semblait pas une seconde et on le dévore
alors sa salle il s'arrête en 63 on
attend avec impatience le tome 2 qui
couvrira justement l'élection
présidentielle de 65 sans doute d'autres
révélations encore que ce soir il en a
fait quelques unes dans l'émission
toujours sûr
de gaulle et bien il ya le la couture
évidemment de gaulle tome 3 le souverain
paru points histoire et puis alors
l'histoire la république gaullienne qui
avaient été publiées il y à 24 ans aux
éditions fayard et réédité ces temps-ci
chez plurielles et c'est évidemment
l'histoire de pierre viansson-ponté en
deux volumes l'histoire république
gaullienne c'est un livre extraordinaire
livre de base peut dire on s'en sert
tout le temps si on veut parler de ça et
enfin du côté de la gauche et bien du
côté de la gauche d'abord je signale que
le coup d'état permanent dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure et a été republié de
françois mitterrand évidemment en 10 18
gilles martinet que nous avons vu de là
plusieurs reprises dans l'émission a
publié sorte de mémoire politiques
sapent les cassandre et les tueurs 50
ans d'une histoire française chez
grasset sur les relations entre françois
mitterrand et mendès-france françois
stas a publié la morale de l'histoire
aux éditions du seuil très bon niveau 6
est très important et a à la fois
agréable et très important sur le fond
catherine et françois mitterrand le noir
et le rouge ou l'histoire d'une ambition
c'est donc une biographie de françois
mitterrand vous aussi un très beau coup
très bonne biographique beaucoup
d'anecdotes d'histoires et très bon
parcours j'ai passé il a été apprécié
par le principal intéressé mais enfin et
enfin je signale
que vient de sortir à la découverte une
histoire du pays sud par marc cargo qui
était un de ses dirigeants qui étaient
étaient avec michel rocard n'est
dirigeants dans les années 60 qui sort
du pays issue la fondation aga la gc le
premier tome alors là pour les
historiens et ce qu'ils veulent il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de la notation voilà
c'est terminé pour cette fois ci dans un
mois le 30 mars le prochain dossier des
brûlures de l'histoire sera consacrée au
temps de la guerre froide la guerre
froide en france merci